[Music]
in this video you will learn about
database Flags its use cases and how to
configure them for Google Cloud SQL
are you wondering what database blacks
are database flags are configuration
options that enable you to customize the
behavior of your Google Cloud SQL
database
they are used for many operations
including adjusting MySQL parameters
options configuring and tuning MySQL
post Sequel and SQL Server instances
database Flags can be really useful in
multiple scenarios here are a few common
use cases one they are useful for
diagnosing specific problems for example
mysql's locally log can be enabled to
help spot performance problem 2. in some
cases database flags are useful for
resolving specific issues with the
database for example you can increase
Max connection settings to allow more
concurrent Connections three they can be
used to enable event scheduler for MySQL
instance to schedule tasks at regular
intervals for example you can manage the
scheduling and execution of events using
event scheduler
to configure database Flags you must
have Cloud SQL editor role which has the
required permissions to access and
modify all the cloud SQL resources
including database Flags
database Flags can be configured for a
cloud SQL instance when creating an
instance or for an existing instance by
editing the configuration anytime
you can configure them using Google
Cloud console CLI or SQL API remember
the database Flags cannot be configured
using MySQL client today I will show how
to configure database flags for a MySQL
instance using Google Cloud console
let's get started by looking at an
example use case slow query logging
the mysql's locally logging can be used
to find queries that take a long time to
execute by default it is disabled to
save storage but you can enable it when
you need to find slow queries in your
database it logs SQL statements that
take more than long query time seconds
which is 10 seconds by default
let's get into action and configure flag
slow query log at the time of creating a
MySQL instance
go to Cloud SQL instance page
click create instance only choose your
database engine panel choose MySQL give
an ID to the instance I'm giving MySQL
instance set a password for the root
user select the database version for
your instance
remember the database version cannot be
edited after the instance has been
created choose the region and the Zone
where you would like to create the
instance you can customize the settings
for your instance as per your needs in
the customize yours instance section I
will retain the default settings for all
except Flags expand flags and click add
flag search first locery log and select
it choose on for value and click done
create instance
congratulations MySQL instance is
created with the database flag's locally
log enabled
now let's look at another commonly used
database flag Max connections
this is a system variable that controls
the maximum number of clients that can
be served concurrently by a MySQL server
instance it is set with a default value
of 4K for most machine types if more
clients attempt to connect to mySQL
server and reached the default limit the
clients will get the error too many
connections
as all available connections are in use
by another client
to resolve this error you can increase
the value of Max connection to a
suitable value on your MySQL server
instance maximum allowed value is 100k
let's now increase the max connection
values to the MySQL instance that we
just created
go back to the cloud SQL instance Page
open the instance MySQL instance and
click edit scroll down to the flag
section and click add flag
search for Max connection
set an appropriate value 5K
click save to save your changes confirm
your changes under flags on the overview
page
for more details about configuring
database flags and supported Flags check
out the following documents thanks for
watching
[Music]